and joining me in the studio for more on
how biotech organisms are used to clean
up the environment is another research
expert from the helmholtz centre dr
lucas vick thank you very much for being
with us today though okay now we saw in
that report how microorganisms can be
applied to clean up groundwater now you
work with fungus how does that work well
we basically work in soil and franchiser
they are the biggest biomass actually
microbial biomass in soil you can expect
to have between two and fifty tons of
fungi per hectare of soil so they're
ubiquitous they're only present and they
have long mycelium and this fungal
network as we call it can spread up to
one kilometer per gram of soil so
they're everywhere and they can link
sources of contaminants with sources of
nutrients and you are unique both
actually for degradation bacteria are
single standing there very small and
they only can act on the spot where they
are and this is a big difference with
respect to metabolic activity fungi they
can degrade a wide range of different
structures they just destroy
disintegrate by on specific enzymes
bacteria however are very specific on
the degradation what they want to
degrade okay now people non-scientists
watching perhaps my questioning the
safety of these microorganisms you know
there are fears that introducing
genetically modified organisms into the
environment can can produce unintended
consequences so what kind of testing is
done to prove that the fungus is safe
well very easy we do not want to put new
fungi to the soil we want to use the
fungi which are already present there so
we think they're naturally there so we
want to promote their capacity to
degrade chemicals in interactions with
bacteria so I think no specific testing
is needed of course we have to know if
this Tanja if they have the right
habitat grow to a certain extent
and they have maybe a biomass which is
dangerous if the fungus was pathogenic
so we have to look for the diversity of
fungi in the soil if you want to be
absolutely sure whether there's some
some pathogenicity existing but I doubt
so all right and then well what would
have what happens then afterwards after
these organisms clean up the the
intended target how do you dispose of
them if they don't agree on their own
they will disintegrate so if the
compounds are not there any longer what
they what they want for degradation they
will start to die and then they will be
decomposed by other organisms which will
live on on the remains of the fungi and
bacteria so I think this is a natural
cycling and that's also part of how
maybe you Mick substances in soil are
produced so this is very natural cycle I
think there's no fear with respect to
that okay all right well we thank you
very much for this discussion today dr.
Lucas Vic welcome